[Music]
now you guys can't say much about season
two but where does it pick off it kicks
off a few months after season one but
that's been sad already so that's why
that's why we're gonna learn more about
your guys's relationship on the show
clay and Hanna I don't know I mean like
I feel like there's a lot of new story
that are going to learn and a lot from
the past like in a familiar timeline
that we already know whether that
involves clay and Hanna I'm not sure
yeah I think it's going on that we you
know if we take off a few months after
you know with finished season one
there's a lot of continuation in the
dialogue I think you know this season
particularly is a lot about recovery
looking at Jessica looking at the people
who are affected and just going from
where we left off in season one and and
not finishing there how do you feel like
the reaction in the conversation that
came from season one affected how you
guys went into season two that's a
really good question I mean I definitely
like personally I was conscious of it
you know when you have such a big
response all these other elements of
being an actor start to come into play
but I think at the end of the day
everyone on the show is very committed
to to telling the story and the moment
that most authentic way possible and so
I think everyone is very focused on just
trying to do the best work possible I'm
not letting any kind of external
thoughts or opinions affect that it's an
emotional unset the season I remember
that everyone told me to drain season
one there was a lot of emotions lying
around when you guys are filming season
one it's an emotional story and I think
that with season one it's all growing up
to a very kind of a huge emotional
climax we're not that far into it yet
but I think it's definitely naturally
it'll be this much of a spoiler is
naturally going to progressively get to
more of an emotional place and due to
the nature of the story we're telling so
I'm sure we're all heading in some dark
directions again how crazy is the
confidentiality with these scripts then
it's actually really you know funny we
asked about you know season one and
emotional and I was gonna say season
this season feels like a very different
show not just think of the
but also just because of you know the
approaches and precautions that we've
had to take but yeah but we're looking
off to the story as best we can and
trying to make sure that we put
everything into place so that the
audience can have the best experience
possible about that first premiere
episode because I know you guys have
already shot it it's juicy that's so
that's all right I'll come up with only
because you know last season we kind of
actually introduced some people give
backstory and this season we can kind of
hit the ground running season two is all
original content we're starting from
scratch
and you can see some of the other
characters developed that we're not so
developed in season one or in the book
you know you can see more of an ensemble
how involved is Selena Gomez this time
around she's always involved she's
always involved she's always checking in
she's always making important decisions
given importance oh she's boss I love
her
[Music]
you